so let's do a little bit of self
reflection
um and estimate your value I mean if you
were to give yourself a ranking on from
one to ten with 10 being the most value
like the best version of yourself and
one being the worst version where would
you place yourself right now on a scale
one to ten six okay so you're six out of
ten what do you think you would need to
do to be a 10 out of 10.
uh
every my friends say Jim
urging me to Jim
um
and I'm kind of lazy about that but that
because I
I don't know I just I don't really want
to do it it's just totally
procrastination
you don't see the importance of
self-care or you don't want to do it for
women or you party well women but I only
want to do it for women but like I do
cardio already like
at least like I was doing like three
miles of biking a day when I was in at
Uni so yeah
okay so like I just I mean like staying
healthy like I kind of already do that
so Jim would be more like you know like
for my my ego or like you know women
really so like are you under the
impression that going to the gym is just
to get women or no but
as I said I'm just kind of like
I'm just kind of I've been
procrastinating about it I mean your
friends have given you some some
valuable advice and said you know you
should go to the gym but do they train
yeah one of my good friends um
has done a lot of a lot of working out
okay so what's stopping you from going
to the gym with him
aside from being like lazy right
I don't know it's just I I I don't
I've I don't feel up to that's it's just
my own like okay you're um you said
you're five foot six I think yes okay
and what do you weigh right now
110. so you're 110 pounds five foot six
yes
okay
do you think that you could get yourself
like
I think you're vastly underestimating
the Optics and the importance of
masculinity and strength
yeah um I could definitely get myself
like a higher away
like
110 pound male is very very light like
I mean like how can I put this I mean
I've dated women that are five five that
weigh more than 110 pounds
yeah like you're very very light and and
I would I would argue that 110 pounds of
at five sixes is frail
yeah I mean like saying that I don't
feel like it or that it might be too
much work and I'm not sure you know what
it is or where that's from but it's like
even if it's not for girls even if you
don't want to do this because you don't
want to impress women or that it's not
about that at all being physically fit
and physically strong has many other
benefits Beyond just attracting women
right like people will look upon you
more favorably in in your workplace when
you're applying for a job when you're uh
like if you're 110 pounds five foot six
you're more likely to be a target of a
crime right like I've never I I'm I'm
six foot two and I've usually weighed
around 195 to 200 pounds 203 pounds you
know is usually what I spent most of my
20s in and like I've never had anybody
try to fight with me right like people
just leave me alone and you walk
differently you hold yourself out to the
public differently you know people look
at you differently when you're in a
physically strong body and you don't
have to be tall to be in a physically
strong body in fact you have a very
significant Advantage being your height
at five foot six to put on muscle
because smaller guys put on muscle much
faster and it looks a lot more
impressive a lot quicker right like the
distance between
um like joints you know for me is going
to be a lot longer than it is a guy like
you and I know this because I have a
friend we used to call him pocket
Hercules he was about five foot five he
wasn't even five foot six but we used to
call this friend of ours pocket Hercules
and we would go to the gym and this guy
was Jack right like he would just look
at weights and he would put on muscle
right like you're missing a huge
opportunity living optimally in your own
body for your own reasons with the
benefit of being attractive to women
yeah I get that um I used to do a lot of
like cows calisthenics like push-up
sit-ups pull-ups I did that like two
years ago probably
I don't I just got busy with like school
and like like just like allotting my
times did you put on much weight when
you're ready no I didn't put on weight
it was during the pandemic so I was
doing school from remote school so I had
more time to work out okay but you
didn't put on any weight when you're
doing the calisthenics push-ups chin-ups
all that kind of stuff
I don't think much no I I saw like I got
more like my arms were more toned okay
other than that no not more weight did
you enjoy it like did you like looking a
little bit better
I liked it um I liked I felt very like
good in my body
um
but and that girl I went out with
actually like
notice it was like you have
noticed it but um
I uh I don't know I just stopped because
I I felt like it was a lot of it was
work and I I wanted to put that work to
like school and education
so you're downplaying the significance
of living in a strong body I would I
would say at five foot six
and I want to hear from the chat here as
well too but I would say at about five
foot six you should aim
well my buddy at five five used to weigh
about 155 pounds so I would say 155 to
160 pounds
like you're 50 pounds underweight
all right that's a good
130 for first Target I guess
well I would I would aim for at least
155 at five six okay muscle I mean like
that at your age it's it's super easy to
just put on muscle and not and not gain
fat I mean you've got a lean figure
anyway
um doing the cardio is fine you can
probably pull back on it a little bit
but I would get a gym membership with
your friend set a schedule uh make sure
make sure you're eating calorie dense
food like what do you usually eat like
what's your diet look like
um
I've been eating a lot I eat like
oatmeal
um
just a lot of weight range of things
like pasta uh oatmeal um I try not to
eat a lot of red meat but I do have like
um I cook like I make like salads
um
I've if I'm not feeling up to cooking
um like I'll make like chicken and pasta
if I'm not feeling up to that I'll just
order in like Mexican Cuisine or pasta
or sandwich
um
I don't like to eat like processed foods
and never felt good about that okay well
I mean like you're eating pot like I
mean pasta is basically going to turn
into sugar in your body right because
it's carbs
um
are you able to get one gram of uh
protein per pound of body weight in you
I mean it should be easy at 110 pounds
because all you need is 110 grams of
protein daily
I'm not sure probably I can do that so
again I mean watch this replay and my
friend you have a lot of work to do like
I can tell you right now I mean if you
want
your question shouldn't be how do I get
a girlfriend your question should be how
do we become a competent strong virtuous
masculine man because again I've been
doing that I've been doing that in areas
I've other than than body okay so tell
me about the areas that you've been
doing that in the career
um definitely career I built a website
um I've really leveled up my LinkedIn
and gaining experience in career so I
have like a trajectory after I graduate
um
um so you've really so you see value in
your LinkedIn
in my Instagram yes okay
um
what value is in your Instagram and in
your LinkedIn right now
well my LinkedIn I feel like it really
uh provides me a kind of a
um
what do you call it like an air up space
where I can kind of like display my
achievements and my Ambit ambition and
what I want to do with my wife and
my social media is kind of where I would
I like display my life and my interests
and
and what I'm doing
okay
um uh I mean I'll tell you from the
perspective of somebody that's
successful worth eight figures LinkedIn
is a pilot is a steaming pile of
horseshit it's it's really not that
valuable unless you want to really uh I
mean move through jobs like if you want
to move through
and hold your resume out to the to the
public like to me the value of what
you've built here on your LinkedIn is is
utterly pointless if you're 110 pounds
at five six right like
saying that I have accomplished these
things and I've gone to these schools
and I've worked here
even if I was an employer which I'm not
anymore but I've employed hundreds of
people and I've terminated a lot of
people too even if I was an employer if
you came into me and I was considering
you as a candidate at five six hundred
ten pounds uh slightly awkward slightly
anxious you know dealing with stuff
depending on the position like unless
it's like dealing with a computer
directly all day long I would I would
definitely pick somebody else right
because I would take one look at you
like people get judged on how they look
right like how you look matters like
women will judge you based on your looks
you're fortunate in the regards that
you're getting your foot in the door
with a date because you're a genuinely
uh good looking guy like you've got good
bone structure like you're I mean you're
very lean obviously so you're going to
have good bone structure in your face at
that weight but
um you're not an ugly guy right like
there's guys that have a lot harder
problems you know when it in the looks
department but the problem is is that
you're just so small and frail and women
want to look up at at a a guy like they
want to
be with somebody that looks like they
can they can be protected by this guy
like
I talk about this in the book there's
there's Engineers that have collected
data on women's search habits when it
comes to
um you know their fantasies and there's
another book out there called a billion
Wicked thoughts which sort of like
breaks it all down as well in other
details but but women's top searches
that really arouse them vampires surgeon
billionaire uh werewolves you know like
these are people and things that that
have personalities of of strength virtue
and have the capacity for extreme
violence as well too right
um or damage you know if you look at it
that way
um
one of the areas that you definitely
need to fix and and take a lot more
seriously is like you got to get your
physicality sorted out and it's and it's
easier for you to go from 110 to 150.
sorry I'm not going to say it's easier
it's
it's going to be an easier path I'll put
it that way than going from 300 pounds
down to 150. if you see what I'm saying
right because you're already lean like
you're already Skin and Bones basically
and I know what that looks like because
I was skin and bones when I was
16. like I started lifting weights
around 16 maybe 15. I remember my dad
gave me Charles atlas's uh mail-in flyer
it was called Dynamic tensions at the
time and it was doing mostly push-ups
calisthenics you know push-ups chin-ups
um you you do some body resistance
motions
um and I was again you know I mean I've
shrunk a little bit I was just about six
foot three around that age but I was 130
pounds like I was light like Skin and
Bones basically right so I know what
it's like
but you have to get in the gym you got
to put the Reps you got to eat the
calories you got to consume the protein
you got to have a gram of uh protein for
every pound of body weight
um I've got a supplement line that has a
great protein solid you know supplement
I've got a testosterone booster in a
lineup there's lots of things that you
can do to supplement going to the gym
picking up everything and putting it
down but you can't substitute
doing the work like you have to put the
time in like you have to do the work
it's it's like there there's nothing in
my opinion that has a better return on
investment than going to the gym in a
man's life when you when you become
older one of the most important things
you have to have on your body if you
want to live into your
um
let's just call them live well through
the Autumn years of your life is you
need lean muscle mass
right and if you lack lean muscle mass
you will die young and you will have a
weak and you know pitiful existence in
the later years of your life like you
have to have muscle mass on your body
yeah
yeah I understand that uh as I said
uh people have encouraging me you know
um and I was doing doing the workouts
for a while but I just stopped because
of time but I I have all the time in the
world you're just a student right like I
have I have businesses that I run I got
to be a parent I got to be a brother I
got to be a son I got to be a boyfriend
I got to be a business owner I got to be
a landlord I got to be like I have to be
all of these things right so how do you
not have time to go and I'm in Combat
Sports too right like I box like I had a
boxing competition earlier this year
I've been doing it for three and a half
years like you can't possibly have an
excuse at 23 for not going to the gym
that's just lazy it is lazy yeah I admit
it I mean it's lazy but uh all right I
can change that good I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out